dank streitet deutschland auch noch
heftig über die einführung einer
sogenannten co2 steuer
viele bürger denken spontan hey warum
soll ich denn für co2 bezahlen das gibt
es doch überall umsonst
ja dieses farblose gas tatsächlich führt
an einer sogenannten co2 bepreisung wohl
kein weg vorbei wenn wir unsere
klimaziele erreichen wollen ob man das
jetzt mit einer steuer macht wer eine
andere frage
tatsache ist die umweltministerin
arbeitet am entsprechende gesetz und
blog
wenn das fertig ist dann kann man ja
zumindest mal drüber sprechen da eine
co2 steuer spreche ich überhaupt nicht
ach so ja schade
stimmt es ist ja wahr ja ich bin so blöd
natürlich darf man sowas nicht
besprechen
ziel einer co2 steuer wäre energie
sparen und klimafreundliche
energieträger attraktiver zu machen
selbstverständlich müsste man den
bürgern die mehrkosten dann irgendwie
zurückgeben schweden macht das zum
beispiel über die einkommensteuer leider
ist der deutsche staat traditionell
nicht so gut im zurückgeben
ich erinnere nur an die gern zitierte
schaumweinsteuer liebe seit 1902 zahlen
zum erhalt der kaiserlichen flotte
sie meine damen und herren laufen heute
noch für die kaiserliche flotte
und trotzdem ist unser einziges
segelschiff im arsch unglaublich diesmal
nehmen zuschauer diesmal muss es klappen
mit dem zurückgeben
ja bei der co2 steuer so angenommen wie
rechne mal angenommen eine tonne co2
kostet demnächst 30 euro dann würde der
liter benzin sieben cent teurer und ein
flug von hamburg nach münchen 4 euro 20
klimaschutz der gar nichts kostet wird
schwierig und vielleicht sage ich immer
ganz ketzerisch müssen unsere
fluggesellschaften auch mal innovativer
werden
er spricht der kapitän wir haben soeben
unsere reise von 0 meter erreicht und
werden barcelona in sechs bis acht
wochen erreichen
unser freundliches wort personal hat
soeben mit dem service begonnen die
toiletten befinden sich in den gärten
links und direkt von guten hansa die
jüngste komplett klimaneutral
ja
warum nicht
ich habe schon gebucht im sommer geht es
nach thailand
ob jetzt co2 steuer oder ein
funktionierender emissionshandel irgend
sowas sollte kommen jetzt wo die erde
offensichtlich im klimakterium ist co2
muss teurer werden um das problem zu
lösen
oder man stellt sich ganz doof und sagt
einfach welches problem
ich glaube nicht dass es gegen den
klimawandel irgendetwas gibt was wir
menschen machen wir hatten früher heiß
zeiten wir hatten früher kalte zeiten
längst vor der industrialisierung und er
muss es wissen denn er war ja dabei
meine damen und herren peter den mammuts
tatsächlich hat die afd gerade den
klimawandel als großes gewinnerthema im
europawahlkampf entdeckt ja der
flüchtling der zieht nicht mehr so also
kämpfen sie gegen die klimalüge
natürlich gab es eis zeiten aber die
waren nicht menschengemacht und 97
prozent der weltweiten studien haben
null zweifel am menschen gemachten
klimawandel ist der afg aber egal
die machen jetzt ihre eigene
naturgesetze herzlich willkommen zu
wissen mag das afg wissenschaftsmagazin
mit carolin kebekus
hallo liebe zwangsgebühren opfer
zur abwechslung mal bock auf die
wahrheit co2 ist gut sie trinken es in
ihrer apfelschorle
co2 ist in dem champagner den sich diese
fette systemen note jeden morgen zum
frühstück für die kaiserliche führte co2
ist pflanzennahrung wenn wir co2
einspart nehmen wir pflanzen das essen
weg
dieser lauf guckt schon ganz traurig
weil die grünen wollen dass er blödsinn
natürlich brauchen pflanzen auch co2 das
bezweifelt ja kein aber was hilft das
wenn wegen treibhauseffekt alles
verdorrt treibhauseffekt welcher
treibhauseffekt und ramos weg gibt es
nicht
es gibt keinen track ist es gibt kein
treibhauseffekt tatsächlich ist der
treibhauseffekt schulbuch wissen ohne
treibhausgase würde die wärme
ungehindert ins all entweichen ohne
treibhauseffekt ist es eigentlich wissen
schaftlichen hetzen minus 18 grad auf
der erde
das war wirklich stark zu bezweifeln ich
auch nix treibhaus und wo wir gerade
dabei sind der sogenannte rückgang der
gletscher ist auch eine dreckige lüge
hfg forscher haben jetzt herausgefunden
die gletscher rufen gar nicht sondern
die berge wachsen das ist doch was gutes
idioten nennen es klimawandel wir nennen
es wetter gehört wetter die letzten fünf
jahre waren weltweit die wärmsten seit
beginn der klima aufzeichnung ach ja der
schlimme hitzesommer der hatte aber gar
nichts mit co2 zu tun haben die kollegen
von der afb worms jetzt rausgefunden sie
wissen wer schuld ist am heißen sommer
windräder
vor wenigen tagen posten sie windräder
würden dem jetstream das ist ein
weltumspannender wind wirbel energie
entziehen und das sei der grund für den
heißen sondern windräder im grunde große
ventilatoren die posten die hitze von da
wo sie hingehört also von da wo die
[ __ ] bohn
so habe ich das mal standen
wissenschaftlich ja das hört sich gern
die mainstream wissenschaft windräder
sind der feind obwohl sie meistens weiß
sind aber sie töten wahllos insekten
vögel jogger radfahrer und was die
wenigsten wissen wenn keiner guckt
drehen die sich gar nicht die frauen
schweine windräder schlimmer als
flüchtlinge und lügen presse zusammen
sie sahen eine wahlwerbung der afg zu
europa war das war keine werbung mehr
geben
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag überall lassen
ihre texte risiken liegen und ihr lasst
jetzt dass selbst ein beschissenes ab
[Musik]